la tour eiffel ouvre à nouveau ses
portes distanciation sociale oblige les
ascenseurs sont condamnés seule solution
pour gravir la tour
ces escaliers impossible fatiguant me
direz vous alors accrochez vous bien car
certains ont fait bien plus le mémoire
de tour eiffel
il n'y a pas de précédent et paris qui
ne s'étonnent pas facilement l'avait
quand même j'avais jusque là 1945 des
alpinistes confondent mont-blanc et tour
eiffel et à la veille de noël trois
alpinistes encore des hauts risques et
l'ascension la plus extraordinaire est
la plus imprévues 1951 rose gold
surnommé l'impératrice du trapèze vol au
dessous de la dame de fer
si vous avez le vertige fermer les yeux
et ne regardez pas ce qui va suivre
rapidement certains casques ou
comprennent le potentiel de la tour
eiffel combiné à un sport extrême les
exploits s'enchaînent montée de la tour
eiffel en vélo en moto
après un premier record sur la tour en
1891 l'ascension jusqu'au premier étage
en échasses voici le dernier en date la
sanction jusqu'au deuxième niveau en
moto alors ça c'est pour la montée mais
certains avaient aussi une solution
plutôt efficace pour redescendre sans
utiliser les ascenseurs un néo zélandais
de 29 ans alan john hackett s'est jeté
dans le vide la tête la première retenue
simplement par une longue corde
élastique un crochet un pied mais sans
autorisation le risque c'est de voir
arriver la police
après l'exploit c'est pas mal un peu
inconscient et pourquoi nous prenons une
autorisation pour faire cela
[Musique]